بدا منتسب والاتحادات النقابيه الثمانيه
الرئيسيه في فرنسا اضرابا يشمل عددا من
القطاعات الحيويه في البلاد بينها التعليم
والمواصلات العامه والطاقه والمستشفيات
احتجاجا على تعديل قانون التقاعد
وتزاملت الاضرابات مع احتجاجات رافضه
لاصلاح نظام التقاعد ونتابع الان هذه
الصور المباشره من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
رامز ديار نحن الان نقف في الشارع
المؤدي الى ساحه ايطاليا ال- ممتلئه عن
بكره ابيها بمئات الالاف من المتظاهرين
همم المهرجانات الخطابيه التي نظمت على
هامشي هذه المظاهره وتداول فيها عدد من
النقبيين على القائمه كلهم اجمعوا على ان
ورقه الشارع مره اخرى هي في صف النقابات
في مواجهه مشروع اصلاح نظام القعقاعود
الذي تقترحه الحكومه ويرفضه انا قابيون
ويقولون ان مره اخرى وفي الموعد الثاني من
يوم التعبئه الثاني الذي ينظم منذ اعلان
الحكومه عن طرحها هذا المشروع على مجلس
النواب يثبت ان فرنسا وليس العمال فقط
كلهم يقفون في وجه هذا المشروع ويقولون ان
صوت الفرنسيين هو من صوت رئيسه الحكومه
اليزابيث بورن التي صرحت منذ يومين انه لا
مجال للتفاوض على يعني التراجع عن
الترفيهي في سن التقاعد الى ست الى اربعه
و60 عاما ويقولون ان فرنسا تطالب بالابقاء
على سن التقاعد مثل ما هو وتطالب الحكومه
الفرنسيه بالنظر في الحلول البديله التي
تقترحها الاحزاب اليثاريه على مجلس النواب
همم فرنسي ازدهار ال- همم منظموا هذه
التظاهر يقولون ان حاجزا من يوناني متظاهر
قد يتم تجاوزه في هذه الاثناء في عموم
فرنسا وان هذه المظاهره الحاشده في باريس
يتوقعوا ان يفوقوا عدد من يتواجدون فيها
المليون شخص شكرا جزيلا لك من باريس مراسل
الجزيره